le père noël sera plus généreux qu'en
il offrira en moyenne 9 cadeau de noël
selon une étude tns sofres le budget est
fixé à 2 161 euros contre 2,147 euros
l'an dernier mais 26% des personnes
interrogées s'attendent à franchir les
400 euros de dépenses on essaye de
suivre la liste en fonction d'eux pour
faire plaisir aux petits-enfants et en
fonction des prix aussi après c'est vrai
qu'on regarde si on trouve plus ou moins
cher à un endroit en essayant de le
retrouver ce qu'ils aimeraient oui on
suit nist mais bon ils veulent tous donc
on a on refait un petit peu la liste par
rapport à ses goûts et ses envies
donc on connaît je choisis par rapport à
l'ordre de préférence la liste et les
numérotés avec le numéro un en fonction
de ce qu'ils ont choisi on privilégie le
moins cher par rapport à la liste
bien sûr en essayant de favoriser le
premier cadeau choisi le jouet phare de
ce noël 2010 est c'est ça le slime une
sorte de pâte à modeler déstressante
c'est un produit qui est devenue virale
en fait sur internet et notamment sur
instagram ou aux états unis
vous avez plein de d'instagram euse qui
font des vidéos de leurs slime dans
lequel elles viennent mettre des
paillettes des couleurs des textures
différentes voilà donc la grosse
tendance chez les garçons c'est des
toupies c'était à la mode il ya encore
quelques années 5 ans et ses revenues
très très fort et notamment avec les
toupies infiniti nadeau qui soit un
véritable carton qui fonctionne très
bien dans les cours de récré et le but
en fait c'est de faire des battle entre
deux toupie tagro sont enchaînés ficellé
acino ce sont des petits des oeufs dans
lesquels à l'intérieur vous avez une
peluche la surprise aussi est dans le
fait que ne sais pas du tout ce qu'il ya
comme un animal dans de votre offre
hachey mauls
à côté des magasins de jouets il y à
internet 60% des français prévoient
d'effectuer leurs achats de noël en
ligne